le dossier craignant un sujet au coeur
de l'actualité
toute cette semaine mardi le président
américain avait menacé de sanctionner
lourdement la russie en cas d'invasion
hier joe biden a réitéré son soutien à
zelensky le président ukrainien au cours
d'un appel téléphonique à moscou de son
côté dément toujours toutes hostilités
ont fait le point avec notre
correspondante à moscou vera goffman
moscou appelle kia va respecter les
accords de misc c'est la déclaration de
la porte-parole de la diplomatie russe
marya zakharova lors de son briefing
hebdomadaire
pour elle les négociations sur un
règlement pacifique de la crise
ukrainiennes sont actuellement dans
l'impasse je vous propose d'écouter
spécial des mines et howling rémy la
mission spéciale d'observation de l'osce
cee constate le transfert d'armes
lourdes par kiev vers l'est du pays
notamment d'artillerie de gros calibre
et de véhicules blindés
l'utilisation de drones se poursuit
récemment l'union européenne s'est
jointe aux processus de militarisation
de l'ukraine le 2 décembre le conseil de
l'europe a décidé d'allouer 31 millions
d'euros pour une assistance technique
aux militaires à l'armée ukrainienne
cette décision ne contribuent en aucune
manière à la paix dans le donbass pas
s'abstenir au débat la situation en
ukraine a été discuté lors de la
rencontre par visioconférence entre le
président russe vladimir poutine et son
homologue américain joe biden le 7
décembre lors de ce sommet bilatéral
virtuel joe biden a fait savoir que
moscou s'exposerait à de fortes
sanctions entre autres économique en cas
d' escalade militaire autour de
l'ukraine selon un communiqué de la
maison blanche
moscou a balayé à plusieurs reprises les
rumeurs sur des préparatifs d'invasion
de l'ukraine tout en rappelant qu'elle
prenait des mesures pour assurer sa
sécurité si nécessaire
le chef d'état major de l'armée russe
valery guirassy mof a dénoncé le 9
décembre dans la multiplication des
activités de le temps aux frontières de
la russie a qualifié de mensonges les
accusations reliées dans les médias
quant à la prétendue volonté de mouscou
d'envahir le cren